si je sais que parmi les 2500
chroniqueur qu'un jour un jour fait
partie de l'émission vous avez votre
petit préféré un indice un indice elle
est sortie non à vous avez changé de
préférer alors elle est sortie deux ans
le père fouras il s'appelle isabelle
bien sûr c'est un peu c'est la préférée
de tout le monde on sait très bien
depuis 2013 avait fait plus de 1000
émission ensemble à godard on en compte
les sorties de l'émission vous incrire
mieux l'émission ensemble parce qu'elle
met ses boucles d'oreilles sur son site
auto 5 vous avez une relation unique
tous les deux et ça m'a donné l'idée de
créer mais ça fait mal - votre relation
unique ça m'a donné l'idée de créer une
nouvelle fiction 100% française ça
s'appelle un gars une grand mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on perd et conduisait à gauche parce
qu'ils trouvaient là mon grand temps ils
comptent direct 8 qui l'avait remarqué
qu'ils avaient moins de voitures à
gauche qui m'a toujours fait rire
c'était marrant les moi j'ai pas le
permis donc merci quand même
vous avez plus de succès qu'avant je ne
sais pas oui mais je me retourne - du
nom j'arrive pas c'est très marrant
une fois de plus dans l'émission a
démarré on a quasiment tous dit que ça
ne marcherait pas donc pas moi oui mais
vous vous êtes à part mais régulière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est content
ça fait des années qu'on sache pas à ma
chérie mais quand je vois les images
médicales effectivement il serait temps
que je prenne ma retraite est beaucoup
plus belle qu'avant tu monte en grade
toi toi je te dis à un moment je pense
que toi et moi ça va se faire faut se
dépêcher quoi
[Applaudissements]